part of my job now is to travel around
the world and just shows in in different
countries I haven't done a show or an
episode in your native country yet of
Spain how do you think I would be
received in Spain and be honest don't
don't don't be polite
what would they think of me you don't
have to be that honest I mean it I think
nobody would care really they wouldn't
care they wanted to know seem to be I
will make sure that people receive the
way you deserve man in the airport with
key received yes it's no good if you
arrange that cheapens the whole thing if
you go ahead and say please put on tape
you know like please someone go out and
act like you care about opponent that's
no good good that's the only way for
people to care and I will take you to
the bullfighting arena and I will ask
you please to dress like a matador wait
you would take me to a bullfight yeah I
don't you think I would dress how would
I look as a matador you would look great
I mean because you are so tall those and
I tied pads will be like I'm like from
like there and the thing that jacket and
your hair with the with the with a hat I
mean I don't think the bull will have
the balls to get on the arena I need a
cape I would use my hair to talk the
hair would on its own be taunting the
ball ugly yeah and I would use that I
would push it from side to side would
come this way in that way yeah could be
incredible absolutely I know he got sick
of me so long ago